[Musique]
greenpeace on l'a fait une spécialité
les actions coup de poing pour une
couverture médiatique la plus large
possible parmi ces cibles privilégiées
l'industrie nucléaire et edf alors et df
at elle voulu connaître la nature de ses
actions à l'avance yannick jadot
l'ancien responsable des campagnes de
greenpeace en est persuadé de hauts
dirigeants d'eads et viennent d'être
mises en examen soupçonné d'avoir fait
espionner son ordinateur
le fait que des responsables d'edf
soient mis en examen tant a confirmé qu
edf est très impliqué dans cette affaire
d'espionnage nous souhaitons que la
justice remonte au plus haut niveau les
investigations ont débuté en 2006
rapidement les enquêteurs soupçonnent
d'espionnage une entreprise privée de
renseignement la société kargus
consultants à sa tête un ancien membre
des services secrets français lui aussi
mis en examen kargus a travaillé pour
edf mais le groupe dément lui avoir
demandé quoi que ce soit d'illégal et df
personne morale est victime des
agissements de kargus consultants
aujourd'hui nous souhaitons pleinement
collaborer et coopérer avec la justice
pour que dans cette affaire toute la
lumière soit faite le dirigeant de
kargus se dit innocent devant les
enquêteurs seul un informaticien a
reconnu avoir espionné le militant
écologiste
[Musique]